armored vehicles rolled in front of
brazil's congress as lawmakers were
preparing for a crucial vote they were
debating a proposal backed by president
jair bolsonaro to change the electronic
voting system to paper ballots ahead of
next year's elections
chances of approving the constitutional
amendment were already slim
the military parade made them slimmer
bolsonaro's opponents and even some of
his supporters accused the president of
putting the tanks on the street to
intimidate the lawmakers
and say he was threatening democracy
once more
since the first day in power president
bolsonaro has been progressively
destroying brazil's democracy it was
time to stop him and we just did by
rejecting the proposal to change the
voting system
digital ballots have been successfully
used in brazil since
1996 bolsonaro has repeatedly said they
are not to be trusted especially after
recent polls show him losing next year's
election to former president luisinasu
lula la silva bolsonaro supporters took
to the streets to back his unfounded
claims that the 2022 presidential race
will be rigged unless paper ballots are
used
congress put an end to this debate at
least for now
analysts here say that bolsonaro has
been following in the footsteps of
former u.s president donald trump by
casting doubt on the elections that he
may lose
and they believe he'll continue to do so
mauna keanake al jazeera rio de janeiro